So, my name is Ryan. I'm, live in Palo
Alto but I'm from Maryland and I'm lactose intolerant.
>> For everybody out there who doesn't know what lactose
intolerance is, tell us briefly what being lactose intolerant means.
>> in briefly, it means I can't have
milk or other dairy products without experiencing some Discomfort.
>> I see discomfort. And, can you elaborate a little bit on discomfort?
>> Sure. discomfort typically means
it's digestive discomfort. So it's gas, bloating, diarrhea, that sort of thing.
>> is anyone else in your family lactose intolerant?
>> Yes. My younger sister is. But I have
a brother who is not. And my parents are not.
>> Okay. so do you, do you have any experience with this being a genetic
trait, like do, do, does this run in your family, being lactose intolerant?
>> I actually don't know, because most
of my family lives in the Philippines, and they don't drink cow
milk. They have the, they drink powdered milk, and all those, and
non-dairy products. Because it's not as popular there, so it wasn't until
I discovered I was lactose intolerant that I learned anything about it.
>> And when did you discover that you were lactose intolerant?
>> I would say that would be about two or three years ago so.
>> Really? That late in life?
>> Yes. But when I found out I was lactose intolerant, it kind
of explained some things from when I was younger.
because there were times like when I would have
dairy products and I'd be fine, but then there
would be times that if I had too much
I felt, I felt a little gassy, but when
I discovered I was lactose intolerant it kind of
made sense that if I was young and overloaded
on it made sense that, that I would feel discomfort.
>> I see so when you were young
though, you felt like you could have normal amounts.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And you were okay.
>> Right. It wasn't until graduate school,
until yeah about two years ago that I discovered I was lactose intolerant. And I
think it's because that's when it kind of
just. When really, it kind of shut off.
>> Right, right. How'd that make you
feel to sort of discover this about yourself?
>> Well, I guess that it kind of made sense to
me because it explained a lot of things about why I'd
randomly feel sick some days and why I wouldn't other days
and just depending on my breakfast. But it was kind of annoying
>>
[LAUGH]
>> To find out, mostly, because I knew I'd have to either change my diet or.
>> Right.
>> Other things.
>> So what are the kinds of foods you
actually have to avoid if you are lactose intolerant person.
>> I you are lactose intolerant and you are
not taking any type of supplement then you basically have
to avoid anything that has an appreciable amount of dairy
products and so of, obviously I'm not going to be drinking
[UNKNOWN]
milk, ice cream, pizzas with a lot of cheese on it.
taco, taco, American style tacos, doritos, all those things, cake, cheesecake.
>> So what you're saying is that there's a lot of food restrictions?
>> Yes. It is a, there's a lot, a huge part of the diet that is, has dairy
products in it. And so discovering lactose intolerant kind
of makes it more difficult to Get that sort of.
>> So do you find yourself in situations I
guess social situations where you see a food come
out and you're like oh,gosh, I really want that
and then you're like oh, gosh, I can't eat it?
>> Yes, especially, I do try to carry around
lactase pills lactase enzyme pills, but if I don't have
them then yes, if someone's like let's go out for
ice cream! I go, oh, I guess I can't. Or.
>> Yeah.
>> If there's pizza. Especially if people, you know, at the last
minute want to get pizza, or certain, go out for
dinner and we haven't decided, if they suggest pizza,
I kind, I have to go, I don't I
can't really eat that. Are people receptive to this
when you tell them, like if you tell a
group of friends, or even new people, hey I'm
lactose intolerant, you know, can we do something else.
Or can we go somewhere else? Are people normally receptive?
>> Yes. especially in California actually. Because in California a lot
of people are, know people with various dietary restrictions or are on
different diets. And so it's definitely it hasn't really affected
my social life. It just means that we do something else.
>> You mentioned lactase pills. What exactly is a lactase pill,
and where do you get it? How much does it cost?
>> A lactase pill is just a little pill,
about an, a little less than an inch big, by
a quarter inch, that is just, a number of units
of lactase enzyme. So lactose intolerance means, my body doesn't
produce lactase anymore, which is the enzyme that breaks down
the lactose sugar into two different sugars. So, this pill, I
eat it, I always buy the fast act pill so
I can just eat it, with my first bite of food
and it kind of dissolves and tries to break down
all the sugars in my stomach. And so I take that
with my first bite of dairy. And then I'm usually good
for about 45 minutes before I have to take another one.
>> Well how much do they cost?
>> I would say it's about ten cents a pill, so
120 would be about 12 to $13 at Safeway, for example.
>> Wow, so it's over the counter.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And you think it's a good deal?
>> I think it's a good deal, because You know especially since I'm
lactose intolerant, I've cut down on the amount of dairy I have incidentally.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So it means that if I am controlling
it one box 128, that's 120 servings of dairy products.
>> Right. That's a lot of dairy. Yeah and, you know,
I switched out the milk I buy for the one that
already is lactose free. So that means I don't have to
take a pill every time I drink a glass of milk.
>> is this a trait you would ever want to change about yourself at all?
>> Definitely. I just feel, I mean being lactose
intolerant just means I can't live my same life.
And eat the same amount of, eat the same foods and do the same things I want to.
But I just have to spend more money. To do it because I buy
the lactase lactose free milk and I
buy the lactase pills to supplement other meals.
>> Are there any advantages to being a lactose intolerant?
>> The only advantage, I would think, is if you're trying
to diet. Like if you're trying to lose weight, you're not going to
be eating the deep dish Chicago style pizzas, or the burritos.
If you're lactose intolerant because even with lactase pills, that might just
still be too much dairy to consume at one time.
So, I mean, that's the only advantage I can see.
>>
[LAUGH].
>> Otherwise, it's just kind of, like I
said, it's an, an annoyance in your life.
>> So do people ever tease you about it like do your friends ever like,
you know will say nicely tease you?
I can't imagine somebody like teasing, teasing you.
>>
[LAUGH].
Well actually, last time I came here, I
walked in, and they were like, oh, you're Ryan,
you're lactose intolerant! And then people were eating
ice cream oh, I guess you can't have that.
[LAUGH]
But yeah, I mean, it's just light-hearted things. It's just like,
oh, I've got my pills, it doesn't matter, and things like that.
>> Have you ever gotten your own personal
genetic information? Done from a company like 23andMe?
>> Yes, I have.
>> And did, what did that tell you about
you being lactose intolerant? Did it confirm this? Or
>> it confirmed I have the, the genotype that is likely
lactose intolerant. Because since lactose
intolerant can also depend on environmental
factors like your, your actual gut bacteria that breaks down the
lactose It means I have the tendency to be lactose intolerant.
But it doesn't mean I am. The only way you can
confirm that you are is to kind of know that you are.
>> You said that you found
out you were lactose intolerant relatively recently.
Did you have the personal genetic information before or after you knew that?
>> it was afterwards.
>> Oh it was after.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, okay.
>> So I knew I was lactose intolerant. And then I got the 23andMe.
And it said Yes, you have the genotype that is likely lactose intolerant.
>> Okay.
>> I said, well, yes.
>> You were like, yes, correct.
>> It's like, when I, you know, you see the 23 and, you are
likely, you likely have brown eyes. And I look in the mirror and go yes.
>> Yes, you are correct 23andMe. So you say
the lactase pills work, the ones you take, you say
they're fast acting? And then you take one and your
normally good for like 45 minutes. are there other types
of lactase pills out there?
>> Sure. There's another type of lactase pill
that's more slow acting. And they're generally a little
cheaper. But, that one you have to take about
half an hour, in advance of eating any dairy.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And so, for that kind. That means you have to kind
of plan ahead of what you're eating. Whereas Since I don't like that,
but in terms of planning my meals, oftentimes I'm just, I take
just the fast act pills because it allows me to make quick decisions
on food.
>> And can you take two of your fast acting
ones at once to last longer, or does that not work?
>> I, I don't know about it lasting longer, but if I'm eating
a large thing of dairy, so like I mentioned before, the deep dish Chicago
style pizza, I'll take two. I'll take two at that first bite, because
I know it's a lot to process, so taking two at once would help.
>> What would you say, if you could give advice to somebody
who, let's say we're talking to Ryan three
years ago before he found out he was lactose
intolerant and he, you know, just discovered That your
lactose intolerant. What advice would you give that person?
>> I think the first advice would be to test your limits on lactose tolerance.
So I can have a bite of ice cream or one nacho with cheese or
[UNKNOWN].
So like knowing your limit on what you
can have without any kind of supplement is useful
and also to just Make the decision whether
you're going to change your diet or buy the
pills or some kind of combination of both,
just kind of figure it out, or, and look
into lactose free alternatives to milk or, they even
have lactose free ice cream now, but it's very
expensive, so it's like.
>> Sure. Is it worth it to buy the ice cream so you don't
have to take pills or do you want to take pills every single time you eat
ice cream sort of thing. It's kind of just decide all the different ways
to manage your lactose intolerance and figure out which way is the best for you.
>> Can your lactose intolerance get worse over time, or have you noticed, you
know, that you've become even more intolerant
now that you use maybe the lactase pill?
>> yes,
I would definitely say I've become
more lactose intolerant since I discovered it.
When I discovered it, I still could have a single serving of dairy,
>> Mm-hm.
>> And not experience symptoms, but now it's to the point where I can't
even have a full serving of dairy. I can't have an eight-ounce glass of
lact of regular milk without experiencing some
symptoms so yeah I think definitely it's
been, I've been more lactose intolerant over the time but I don't know what
causes that if it's just the fact that my
body is producing less, and less, and less and
that's a gradual thing or if it has anything
to do with supplementing it or not having normal lactose.
>> huh.
>> So, but I'm not sure.
>> Well thank you for coming in and chatting with us.
>> Yeah, thanks for talking to me. I don't get to talk about this that often.
[LAUGH]